Arguments will often make me cry.
I've inherited this from my mother...
...which is like you get really frustrated and angry...
...and then you start crying and they're like, "What's wrong?"...
...and you're like, "I'm just so angry at you."
Management to me provokes emotional reactions often, in part,...
...because I care for people and I care for the people that I supervise.
And so, the moments that stick out to me when I've cried have been about that.
For me, it's always a combination of being tired, being stressed...
...instead of getting in a mentality where I'm already feeling sorry for myself...
...and then in some way that becomes reinforced.
And then I just get into a very "woe is me" frame of mind...
...and then start crying.
So, we've got taking deep breaths.
Just telling yourself not to cry.
But if you can't stop the tears from coming, maybe just don't worry about it.
Crying is a normal part of work.